okay morning scarcely okay so let's talk
is joint work with
the Millea who is here and Williams was
in the back there and Stefan our and
Mohit Singh and so the topic of this
talk is to understand how well systems
perform under strategic behavior this is
one of the overarching themes in
algorithmic game theory and there's been
a lot of work and in on this question so
imagine that we have a system that has
many participants and as a central
planner you might have some global
objectives that you want to achieve
through the system but every participant
has their own individual goals that they
want to optimize for and so the
participants take actions that may not
align with the objective of optimizing
the global the global behavior of the
system and so the question we want to
ask is in equilibrium when everybody
takes the action that is best suited to
them how well does the performance of
the system compare against the optimal
that could be achieved if everybody was
cooperating okay and in many situations
there are many different equilibria that
can arise in settings such as this and
so going with the beyond worst case
theme of this workshop you know the
questions which equilibrium are we
analyzing and in this talk we are not
going to be looking at the worst
equilibrium or the best equilibrium but
rather something that emerges through
some sort of natural dynamics in this
game okay and we'll see that you know
the this question is very closely
related to thinking about how well
algorithms perform when there's some
sort of restriction on the set of
actions that the algorithm can take
name
that every such action should correspond
to behavior of a self-interested agent
okay so we're gonna focus on a specific
setting where there's a big gap between
what worst case equilibria look like and
what best case equilibria look like so
that this question becomes interesting
and we're gonna give an analysis for
that specific game but before we move
forward I want to start for the
disclaimer there's been a very nice
emphasis over the last day and a half on
you know practical motivations towards
algorithm design I'm going to depart
from that and do this purely theoretical
exercise with the goal being to
understand you know what kinds of
approaches can we take to analyzing
algorithms within this sort of a very
restricted action space okay so this is
the game that we are going to talk about
this is called the broadcast game and
it's a special case of a class of games
that are called Network design games so
the goal here so we're given this graph
or a network and there are costs on
edges and there's a route okay and every
agent in this game is an agent that
resides at one of these nodes okay and
the goal of these agents is to buy a
path that connects to the route and so
the solutions that we expect to see here
are essentially spanning trees okay and
the global objective that we're trying
to minimize here is the cost of such a
spanning tree so for example you know
this could be one particular solution in
this example the total cost of the
solution is 15 and this also turns out
to be the minimum spanning tree for this
graph
and the agents are gonna share the cost
of the spanning tree and so are we going
to look at what's called the Shapley
cost sharing namely that the cost of
every edge is shared equally by every
person that uses it so for instance if
you look at this edge okay so in green
here are the paths that the different
agents are taking and so this edge is
shared by all five of the agents in this
graph and so its cost is going to get
shared equally by all of these five
agents this edge is shared by three and
so its cost is going to be shared by
three agents and so on okay and so in
particular the cost share of this guy
here is 4 plus 3 by 3 plus 5 by 5 okay
so that's the structure of the cost
shares we can write down these cost
shares for every terminal for the
solution and every particular terminal
in this graph is interested in
minimizing their own cost without
worrying about the total cost of the
solution do you have a question very
good question so indeed an equilibrium
is always going to be a tree and I'll
shortly tell you why yeah okay so every
agents goal is to minimize their own
cost share so if you look at this
particular agent over here this guy is
currently paying the cost of 6 but it
could in fact switch from its current
path to this one and pay the cost of
this entire path by himself okay and
still save on his cos here okay and so
this terminal is gonna want to switch
okay and when he does that of course the
total cost of the solution goes up okay
so you can see that the optimal solution
here is not necessarily an equilibrium
in the sense that everybody is happy
with that solution okay and of course
when this guy moves away from this path
everybody else on that path sees their
cost share increase okay
and so potentially now some of these
guys are not happy anymore with their
pads and so for instance this guy now is
paying two plus three halves plus five
fifths on his back and if he shifts to
this one and he only played pays three
plus five fifths and so this this
particular terminal also wants to shift
and now it turns out that this
particular configuration is an
equilibrium in the sense that no
terminal wants to deviate from their
current path to a new path unilaterally
okay so that's an equilibrium in this
game and you can already see from this
example that equilibria could be more
expensive than the minimum spanning tree
in the scheme okay so the question that
we want to ask is well how good are
these equilibria or how how large can
their cost be relative to the minimum
spanning tree and as I mentioned earlier
one problem that's such a question is
there could be multiple equilibria of
different qualities and so to deal with
this you know with the first case
mindset that we tend to have in theory
kutsu pious and papadimitriou define
this notion of the price of anarchy of a
game and this is defined to be this is
like an approximation ratio and it's
defined to be the approximation ratio
achieved by the worst equilibrium in the
first instance of the game now for the
broadcast game this ratio can actually
be really large and let me show you an
example where it is really large so here
this is the root again and we have n
agents residing at this other node and
there are two paths one of which is very
cheap and the other is really expensive
it has a cost of N and of course if
everybody was to you know take the cheap
edge then this would be an equilibrium
but this is not the only
Philippa him in this game so if you
imagine everybody taking this long back
to the root then everyone's cost share
is n divided by n or one and nobody
wants to switch to the cheap path
unilaterally okay and so for this
particular example for this equilibrium
the price of n our key is of almost a
factor of n okay so that's pretty bad
okay but observe that this is a really
strange example so you'd really have to
force all the in n agents to go on that
long path in order for this to be an
equilibrium so unless they all collude
to pick a bad solution in this
particular example that's not the
equilibrium that you would expect to see
okay and that's kind of the point of
what we are trying to do here you know
we don't want to you know think of this
n as being really the performance of
this game because this equilibrium is
never gonna emerge okay so this the
broadcast game and a more general family
of network games was proposed by
inshalla which at all and they came up
with the concept of the price of
stability to deal with precisely this
issue that you don't expect to see that
the kind of equilibria that I showed you
on the previous slide okay so the price
of stability measures the quality of the
best equilibria in an instance of the
game and again you're taking the worst
case overall instances but the best case
over equilibria of that instance and
then again it's an it's like an
approximation ratio sorry where's that
price instability good question so it's
called the price of stability because
it's basically saying that you know if a
central planner were to come and suggest
a solution to every agent then the
agents would actually be happy with that
solution in the sense that it's an
equilibrium and no one wants to
unilaterally deviate so
so the best equilibrium is telling us
that if we could somehow enforce the
solution then it would be stable nobody
would want to move okay and so inshallah
Vichy and I'll also showed that the
price of stability in any such Shafi
Network game is small relative to the
price of Anarchy and this is basically
through a sort of potential function
argument so there is a class of games
called potential gains where you can
assign a potential function to every
possible state of the game with the
property that if anybody wants to
deviate from their current strategy then
the the change in their in the in their
cost share is captured by the change in
potential okay and that allows us to you
know do various sorts of arguments on
the existence of equilibria and such so
let me describe the potential function
for this particular game and it looks
like this so there's a sum over the
edges off the cost of the edge and note
that if we didn't have this extra term
here then this would just be the cost of
the current solution all of the edges
that that somebody is using and let's
denote by n sub even number of people
that are using this edge e then the
potential for this edge is this the the
end sub yet harmonic number okay so you
take one plus one half so until one over
n sub e and the observation here is that
the last term in this potential function
for any particular edge is precisely the
the cost share that any terminal using
that edge sees for this edge okay so if
there are any people on edge e then the
cost share for any one of those on this
edge is precisely C so B over N sorry
okay so what does that mean that
basically it tells us that if you if you
take
and you move them from one path to
another then the potential on the edges
in the old path decreases by precisely
this last term which is the cost share
of the terminal on those edges and on
the new edges the edges in the new path
it increases by precisely what the new
cost share of the terminal is on those
edges so the change in potential from
one agent moving from one path to
another is precisely the change in the
agents cost share so if an agent wants
to move and decrease this cost share the
potential decreases and now you can
imagine you know thinking about a series
of such moves where people in sequence
you know try to improve their cost
shares and this potential keeps
decreasing every time a potential game
is just a game where you can define such
a potential function doesn't have to be
exactly of this form but I mean you can
define a potential where every improving
move is going to decrease this potential
and the change in potential is precisely
the change in the cost share of the
agent
so what are some implications of this so
first of all this potential starts out
at some finite value decreases every
time this process is going to converge
to some local optimum for this potential
function and any such local optimum is
going to be an equilibrium of the game
okay so equilibria always exist there
could be multiple equilibria because
there could be multiple local optima and
for this specific game one can use this
the the form of this potential function
to also argue that the price of
stability is small in particular think
about the global optimum state for the
potential function then the cost of such
a global minimum is going to be no more
than the the potential at the minimum
spanning tree which is no more than a
logarithmic factor off of the cost of
the minimum spanning tree and all we are
using here is that this potential is at
least as large as the cost of the
solution and no more than a factor of
log and off so that shows that there's
some equilibrium that is at most of log
and worse than the MST in terms of cost
yes it is the same potential function
for contrast
so I'm gonna talk about improvements on
this particular bound this is an upper
bound yeah yeah so for general network
design games actually this analysis is
tight there's an example where the price
of stability is exactly log of n and
here's the example so here this is the
route the terminals are all here okay
and we have an extra node here and every
terminal has two potential paths to the
root and observe that this graph is
directed so there is every terminal has
only two different paths one goes
through this extra steiner node and has
this one plus Epsilon cost the other
path has different costs for different
terminals but observe that a solution
where everybody tries to follow the
cheap path here okay which is in fact
the the optimal solution for this graph
it's not a stable solution because
everybody sees a cost share of 1 plus
epsilon over N and so this last guy has
an alternate path of cost 1 over N is
gonna want to switch but once this guy
switches everybody sees a cost of 1 plus
epsilon over n minus 1 and then the the
second-to-last guy here is gonna want to
switch because his alternate path costs
1 over n minus 1 and so on okay so the
only stable solution in this example is
one where everybody takes their
individual edge to the root and the
total cost of the solution is log of n
as opposed to the optimal solution that
has a cost of 1 plus epsilon this is the
only equilibrium in this
okay so Angela Wichita basically gave a
tight bound for the price of stability
and observed that this is already an
exponential improvement over the price
of anarchy bound that we saw which was n
in the worst case okay but we're going
to be looking at a special case of this
game one where you don't have any
steiner vertices so every vertex in the
graph is a terminal and wants to connect
to the root and furthermore the the
graph is undirected okay so here the
fact that the graph is directed was
important in showing that you get a
price of stability of exactly log of n
so there are improved bounds that are
known for price stability we showed that
in undirected graphs you can get a
slight improvement from the log n bound
and when we talk about broadcast games
namely those where every vertex in the
graph has a terminal residing at it then
there's there's a succession of papers
that give progressively better bounds
and this terminated and an O of one
bound so there's some large constants
such that there's you can always find an
equilibrium of the game that's within
this constant factor of the optimal
solution so there's all of this nice
work and much of it basically proceeds
by starting with the optimal solution
and then making some very careful
modifications to it so as to convert it
into an equilibrium and these
modifications these are pretty involved
algorithms and none of them is for
instance computationally efficient so
that you know you can't even compute
these nice equilibria
and then enforce them or suggest them to
the terminals no it's not known that
it's np-hard
but there's no no algorithm known for
computing any equilibrium efficiently in
this game right for the exam okay we
don't know this one um not sure the
Palio might no not known to be died
so there is their somewhat unsatisfying
and that's in the sense that even if you
were to believe that you know a central
planner should compute a good
equilibrium and then suggest it to the
terminals we don't we don't even know of
an efficient way of doing that okay so
to come back to the question that I
stated at the very beginning our goal is
to think of some sort of natural
dynamics that the agents can follow to
converge to an equilibrium and the
question we want to ask is you know what
kinds of dynamics lead to a good
equilibrium what kinds of dynamics lead
to a poor equilibrium okay so what do I
mean by natural dynamics we're gonna
allow three kinds of moves here so
terminals can arrive in the system one
by one and when a terminal arrives it
follows the best path a current path to
the route given the current state of the
system terminals can depart and in
between terminals can make improving
moves which means they can switch their
current path to a new path with a
smaller cost share okay so this sort of
process was first proposed by Chick
Corea tall and they looked at the
following kind of simple dynamics which
was split into two phases so in the
first phase every terminal arrives in
some adversarial sequence and in the
second phase terminals make these
improving moves in some arbitrary order
and there are no departures and they
assured that for this kind of dynamics
this always converges to an equilibrium
that's no more than a factor of square
root of n times some poly log of n times
the optimum okay so it's an improvement
over the price of Anarchy bound and the
analysis of the same dynamics was later
improved by Charikar at all and they
showed that in fact the worst
equilibrium you could arrive at through
this process as no
more than of log squared of n worse than
the optimum okay so this is a huge
improvement over the price of an RT
power doesn't quite get down to O of one
of the price of stability Mon but it's
still pretty good okay and the analysis
of this process yeah so the initial
condition is that the the graph is empty
there are no terminals there are no pads
okay so you start from an empty graph
and then people arrive one by one and
every person that arrives looks at the
current state and takes their best path
at that point of time and then they make
improving moves so the initial condition
is just that the graph is empty so the
first phase is just n arrivals the
second phase the analysis of the second
phase is just in saying that the
potential function decreases as the
process goes on and again there are no
bounds on how long that process takes
because the potential function starts
out at a finite value but in some steps
it might make only exponentially small
improvements and so the length of the
process could well be exponential the
cost gets low just may take a little
while to beat exactly the equilibrium
faction that's right that's right so the
way that this analysis proceeds is that
they basically use a careful dual
fitting to bound how large the potential
is at the end of the first phase and
this basically looks somewhat like the
online Steiner tree algorithm except
that the greedy step is a little bit
different because every person is
minimizing their cost share rather than
just can you know their connection cost
to the current solution so
Oh once you're able to bound the
potential at the end of this first phase
though then things are in good shape
because what happens in the second phase
is that the potential successively
decreases and so the cost of the
solution at the very end is no more than
the potential at the very end which is
no more than the potential that you
started out with at the end of phase one
okay so this this off log squared n is
basically coming from the bound on the
potential at the end of this first phase
but the length of the second phase is
not necessarily bounded because the
potential decreases at in very small
steps sometimes so this is what charter
at all showed and what we do in our work
is to ask well first of all what if you
had departures in this process as well
how does that affect this analysis and
second what happens if you allow these
things to happen and since some
arbitrary interleaving of these
different steps okay what can you then
say about the equilibria that emerge
yeah okay so where are some of the
challenges with doing something like
this well first of all it's very
difficult to maintain any sort of
structural invariant once you let people
just make improving moves as and when
they want in fact you know I said before
in response to a question that
equilibrium states are always trees but
intermediate states of this process
might look very strange with you know
different cycles the you know paths of
different terminals
converging and diverging yeah ok very
good question so I stated before that in
broadcast games every vertex has a
terminal at it so essentially what that
means
sometime in this process a terminal is
going to arrive at every vertex and
potentially leave after that so the
optimum is going to be defined as the
the solution over the entire set of
terminals or the minimum spanning tree
and when you allow for departures it's
important to compare against that opt
and not just the minimum Steiner tree
over the remaining terminals because
that could be very far off so we are
gonna compare the cost of the entire
state at the end of the process against
the minimum Steiner minimum spanning
tree so even if a terminal departs the
node stays in the graph and then we're
allowed to include that and after yeah
any other questions
okay so that's one of the difficulties
that it's tricky to have any sort of
structural invariant as the process goes
on and if we could just somehow argue
that the potential stay is bounded as in
charka at all's analysis then we'd be in
good shape because improving moves only
decrease potential departures only
decrease potential the only thing that
increases potential is arrivals okay but
then again it's it's really tricky to
argue about how much the potential could
jump up by for any arrival if you don't
have any kind of structural property on
what the solution looks like at that
point of time
and there are no agents at the time zero
and then agents are like they yes so
indeed so there's some underlying graph
and you'd like the agents to make their
decisions based on what they see at the
current moment and not other nodes that
are not yet in the process and that's
indeed how our results proceed that's
right yes and if if edge costs satisfy
the triangle inequality then that's
gonna happen for ribose okay so let me
describe our results and then we'll go
into some details okay so first we show
that if it's the sequence of arrivals
departures and moves is completely
arbitrary then things can be really bad
so we can have equilibria that are
polyanin far from the optimal solution
and in fact these examples the bad
examples that we have look like a
sequence of arrivals and departures in
the beginning and then once that
sequence terminates this system is at
equilibrium so in fact there are no
improving moves at all so you could
think of this as just a slight departure
from what charter at all do in the sense
that you add departures to the first
phase and adding departures just makes
things a lot worse okay so that's that's
a negative result and then you might ask
well how can we restrict this process to
make the equilibrium better so our neck
next result says that if between every
successive arrival and departure we're
allowed to make improving moves to bring
the system to equilibrium so in other
words arrivals and departures can only
happen at equilibrium then the worst
case ratio with respect to opt decreases
to off login okay so this is even better
than what charter at all
get and I put worst case here in quotes
because this is this does need a little
bit a little extra assumption which is
that between every batch of arrivals and
departures the sequence of improving
moves is going to be a carefully
constructed algorithmically constructed
sequence of improving moves so an
algorithm suggests terminals one by one
to make and improving go when that that
restores equilibrium but the ordering of
arrivals and departures can be
completely adversarial those are the
results and in the rest of the talk I'm
going to focus on this positive result
and I'll describe why this
algorithmically generated sequence is
necessary okay so here are some of the
key ideas that we need for this to work
out so I said before that if the
dynamics is completely arbitrary then
one trouble is that intermediate states
might not look nice like trees and so we
try to stay within the space of tree
solutions in two ways so when so if you
have a tree solution at some point of
time and some terminal wants to make a
move then we restrict that move to be of
the form where this terminal takes an
edge to another node in the tree and
then follows the tree path to the root
okay and then we also enforce that the
entire subtree of at this terminal
switches to the same new path and so
after the sequence of moves the the the
state is again a tree and these are all
improving moves
okay and then our main analysis consists
of charging the cost of such a tree to a
particular dual solution for the minimum
spanning tree problem and the key thing
that we take care of is to make sure
that every every cut in the dual is
charged at most once one trouble with
this is that this can be temporarily
violated as we go through a sequence of
improving moves and then basically what
we show is that whenever this is
violated there exists some improving
move that is going to fix this
overcharging okay so this is a little
bit different from how dual fitting for
online algorithms typically works where
you maintain some charging structure and
you stay within that here we allow
violating that invariant but then fix it
through improving moves afterwards okay
so a very quick background on how dual
fitting works for the minimum spanning
tree so observe that if this is your
graph and if you can find some number of
nodes that are all pairwise distance at
some distance from each other then this
gives a lower bound on the size of the
minimum spanning tree in particular if
you have K nodes that are each pairwise
a distance of L apart then the minimum
spanning tree has to have cost at least
L times K minus 1 and we can certify
that by drawing balls around these
points each of radius L over two and
these are going to be disjoint this is a
way of constructing a dual solution to
the MST and in fact you can construct
the solution iteratively in a greedy
manner so pick a point draw a ball of
radius L around it pick a point outside
of that ball outside of that ball draw
another ball of radius L around it and
continue doing this until the entire
graph is covered and then the sum of the
radii of these balls within a constant
factor gives a lower bound
or not okay so this is the kind of duel
that we will charge the cost of our
solution to and in fact we will
construct such a duel at many different
distance scales that say powers of two
and it turns out that there are only
logarithmically many distance scales of
interest the rest are too tiny to be of
interest and as I said before so every
role here is a feasible dual within a
constant factor so the sum of the radii
of all of the duels that we have here is
within a factor of log n of the optimal
cost so what are we gonna do with this
well we're gonna try to charge the cost
of a tree to these duels and in
particular we're gonna make every node
in this tree responsible for its
parentage okay now this is different
from the cost share of a node the cost
share of a node is the sum of its cost
shares along all of the edges to the
root but from for the point of view of
charging this node is going to be
responsible for just its parentage so
suppose you have a node V and its parent
edge looks has length roughly two to the
I we're gonna find a row in these duals
that is a radius roughly two to the I or
a little bit smaller than that and then
we're gonna find the ball that contains
V in this row and we're gonna charge
this edge to that particular ball okay
and if we can do this in a way that
every ball gets charged at most once
then we get a bound on the cost of the
solution so what is the bad case here
the bad case is that you could have two
vertices that have edges of roughly
equal length two different parents and
they're very close to each other okay
and when that happens the hope is that
one of these vertices is going to want
to make an improving move here in
particular one of these vertices would
want to sue
to switch to a path that you know goes
to the other verdicts and then follows
its path to the root and why is this a
good idea this is a good idea because
the switching there's some extra cost
that you incur which is tiny and then by
sharing these edges hopefully there's
enough of a saving in cost share that
makes up for this extra cost here we
gonna show that one or the other is a
good idea both might not that's right
the dynamics only allows one move at a
time what's that I'm saying here it
seems important because otherwise that's
right so one will switch at a time and
then the other path goes away so so it's
gonna always be one node at a time yeah
okay so when does this not work so if
it's the case that there are lots of
people on these blue paths for instance
if there's a big sub-tree under you and
another one under B then these goal is
to switch to u so that it gets some
extra saving from extra sharing along
this path but that's not gonna happen if
there are already lots of people the
extra saving is tiny then okay so
basically what we show is that if one of
these was a leaf in the tree then you
get enough enough of a savings so that
either you or V wants to switch in
particular we can write down the new
cost of V from switching to use path in
this manner in terms of the old cost of
U and we can consider a similar switch
for u and write down its new cost in
terms of the old cost of B and if you
add these up you see that either u
improves its cost or V improves its cost
okay and that's the idea here so as long
as one of these guys is a leaf and when
you are in this batch situation one of
them is going to want to switch and
correct that overcharge on the world
so what does this look like overall so
we have some charging of the duel
we're at equilibrium where every duel is
being charged at most once and then some
arrival happens and creates an
overcharge and then this overcharge is
fixed by moving one of these nodes
making an improving move but this only
moves the overcharge potentially to
another duel and then you move one of
those nodes and this shifts the
overcharge again and we continue doing
this until everything every duel is
again charged at most once okay and this
might not be an equilibrium but you can
go through this process until it
converges to an equilibrium and the
potential always decreases so eventually
this process converges okay so we can do
this more generally even there's a batch
of arrivals and departures and that's
the basic idea that there are if a duel
is getting overcharged we can fix these
overcharges okay so to summarize yeah
trying to get some naive intuition about
why the log n all of the edges were off
cost 1 then we'd only be worried about a
single duel and actually we'd get a
constant factor cost so the log n comes
from having to look at log n different
distance scales and edges of different
lengths just by counting I mean I agree
that yeah that's right but in that case
we can actually get a constant that's
what I'm saying yeah that's right that's
right yeah so the log in here is coming
from the different lengths of the
different edges there could be log n
different scales for these lengths and
that's where that comes from
so to summarize the this work gives an
analysis for a min cost spanning tree
algorithm under this restriction that it
needs to respect the agents preferences
and an arbitrary sequence of moves
looks pretty bad but if we if we insist
on restoring equilibrium after each
arrival or departure then we can bound
the cost of the equilibrium that emerges
and I said earlier that we don't know of
any way of arriving at an equilibrium
with in polynomial time so indeed the
process that I described could also take
a long time to converge between every
sequence of arrivals and departures okay
so and and it's also open whether we can
further generalize the house in what
order which doesn't form a cycle with
you know no right yeah so you know the
the greedy online Steiner tree algorithm
tries to find the cheapest connection to
the existing tree whereas this one every
agent is going to look at not just the
cost of the steepest connection but also
how much its cost share is along the
path to the route and so those choices
could be quite different actually and
part of what the chore occur at all
analysis does is to show that there
they're not too different in some sense
whereas here we don't have as much
structure as the process goes on and so
that's not necessarily true that those
two choices are going to be
aproximately yeah yes in some sense it
is true you can bound the you can write
down inequalities that describe the
increase in potential essentially or the
cost share that the agent faces seems
like all the analysis hinges on a
proportional cost sharing mechanism
that's right yeah I mean if you relax
the requirement that would be budget
balance to revenue adequate is there a
reasonable revenue adequate mechanisms
that could improve the worst case that's
a good question I haven't thought about
it at all and there is some work on
people looking at other ways of sharing
cost so as to lead to better equilibria
but these are always budget balanced so
your question I believe is whether you
can move away from budget balance and do
something better and I'm not sure good
equilibrium is that going to be hard I
don't think that a harness result is
known
questions time for lunch